all right lord Cognito here lords of
gaming dotnet and who is here in the
realm today alright so tell us a little
bit about what is so now one couch co-op
a puzzle base that you have to work
together to reach the end right now
maximum amount of players are we looking
at four players Wow okay so now you said
switch correct okay
so switch could go up to eight players I
guess that would be pretty cool man
so again I noticed right now we're kind
of like in the tutorial segment so it's
all about cooperative puzzle solving
right
for the solving platform game but you
have to find a way and sometimes each
other to make like a ropes
[Music]
yes reach right now I'll tell you what
this game reminds me of it reminds me of
another Nintendo's which can cause
sniffer clips do you remember something
now what's cool about that which I liked
is that again like you said where it's
multiple players but you got to form a
team in order to solve the goal to make
like a game because we imagine ourselves
making nice we will be like that
character difficult
sorry to go on the platforms yes and
it's why it's called evil people because
you can little bit difficult to control
your character I see God ship these type
of games are fun but I gotta be honest
these games can ruin friendships if
people don't know what they do like so
as far as like level design like how do
you reach that balance to go between
making something making a problem to be
easily solved together like how do you
get structure with the difficulty of a
game like this cooperatively swing we
show character to jump to center on the
interpreter birthday there is also bikes
nice which gives you so you have to
be very careful about bikes here in our
levels right now so it looks like
they're all trying to band together
right now they've got to get to this
other side right okay so this now how
many levels as far as you're looking at
long term for awesome so when are we
looking at release for heave-ho
and again platforms Nintendo switch
right and how are we looking at as far
as released released a how far along are
we in development alright great party
game it looks fun
you seen everybody having a good time
working together heave-ho we got to keep
my eye on this one man the cooperative
puzzle game fantastic man looking man
I've really enjoyed this opportunity man
thank you so much